Hi.
In this problem, we're going
to look at how to infer a
discrete random variable from
a continuous measurement.
And really, what it's going to
give us is some practice
working with a variation
of Bayes' rule.
So the problem tells us that
we have a discrete random
variable x with this PMF.
It is 1 with probability P,
minus 1 with probability 1
minus P, and 0 otherwise.
So here is just a diagram
of this PMF.
And then we also have another
random variable, y, which is
continuous.
And its PDF is given by this.
It's 1/2 lambda e to the minus
lambda times the absolute
value of y.
And so this may look familiar.
It looks kind of like
an exponential.
And in fact, it's just a
two-sided exponential.
That's flattened by
a factor of 1/2.
And this is what it looks like,
kind of like a tent that
goes on both ways.
And then we have a random
variable z, which is equal to
the sum of x and y.
And the problem is going to be
figuring out what x is, based
on an observed value
of what z is.
So because x is discrete
and y is random--
sorry, x is discrete, and y is
continuous, z is also going to
be continuous.
So our measurement is z,
which is continuous.
And we want to infer x,
which is discrete.
So the problem asked us to
find is this what is the
probability that x equals 1,
given that z is a little z.
And you can write this another
way, just as a
conditional PMF as well.
It's the conditional PMF of
x, given z, evaluated to 1
conditioned on little z.
All right, so now let's apply
the correct variation of
Bayes' rule.
So remember, it's going to be
this, the probability that x
equals 1, or the PMF of x
evaluated to 1, times the--
you flip this conditioning.
So now it's going to be a
conditional PDF of z, since z
is continuous.
It's going to be a conditional
PDF of z, given x, evaluated
at some little z condition
on x being 1.
And the bottom is the
conditional PDF--
or sorry, just the
regular PDF of z.
And of course, we can rewrite
this denominator.
Remember, the denominator is
always just-- you can use the
law of total probability
and rewrite it.
And one of the terms is
going to be exactly
the same as the numerator.
So one of the ways that z can
be some little z is it's in
combination with x
being equal to 1.
And the probability of that
is exactly the same
thing as the numerator.
And the other way is if x
is equal to negative 1.
And that gives us this
second term.
All right.
And now let's just fill
in what all these
different terms are.
So with the PMF of x evaluated
at 1, that is just P. What is
the conditional PDF of z, given
that x is equal to 1?
Well, that takes a little
bit more work.
Given that x is 1, then z
is just going to be--
so if x equals 1, then z is
just y plus 1, which means
that you can just imagine taking
y-- this is what y is,
the distribution of y--
and just adding 1 to it, which,
in this diagram, would
amount to shifting
it over by one.
So now, it would look like
this, the distribution.
And algebraically, all you would
do is just change this
thing in the absolute
value to y minus 1.
That amounts to shifting it
over to the right by one.
All right.
So what is that?
That's just 1/2 lambda,
1/2 lambda, e to the
minus lambda y--
sorry, not y, z--
z minus 1.
And the denominator, well, the
first term is going to be
exactly the same.
It's just also P 1/2 lambda e to
the minus lambda z minus 1.
What about the second term?
The second term, first we need
to figure out what is the PMF
of x evaluated at
a negative 1.
Or in other words, what's
the probability that
x is negative 1?
That is given to
us by the PMF.
It's 1 minus P.
And then the second part is,
what is the conditional PDF of
z, given that x is negative 1?
Well, we can just do the same
sort of trick here.
If x is negative 1, then
z is just y minus 1.
In which case, the PDF of z
would just look like this.
You're shifted to the
left by one now.
And now what you have to do is
change this into a plus 1.
So this conditional PDF would
be 1/2 lambda e to the minus
lambda z plus 1, absolute
value of z plus 1.
All right, so this looks
pretty messy.
And we can try to simplify
things a little bit.
So we can get rid of
these 1/2 lambdas.
And then we can multiply the
numerator and the denominator
by the same term.
Let's multiply it by e to
the lambda absolute
value of z minus 1.
So what we're going to do is
try to cancel out some of
these exponential terms.
So that will cancel
out this top term.
So all we have in the numerator
now is just P. It
will also cancel out this
exponential in the
denominator.
And then we'll have to change
this here, because it'll have
an extra e to the lambda
absolute value of z minus 1.
All right, now let's
rewrite this.
And what we get is plus 1 minus
P e to the minus lambda
absolute value of z plus
1 minus absolute
value of z minus 1.
OK, so that is pretty much as
far as you can go in terms of
simplifying it.
And now the question is, are we
comfortable with this answer?
And it helps always to try to
interpret it a little bit, to
make sure that it makes
intuitive sense.
And one way to do that is to try
to-- some of the limiting
cases of what some of the
parameters can be.
So in this case, the parameters
are P and lambda.
So P is the parameter
related to x.
And lambda is the parameter
related to y.
So let's try to see if it
makes sense under some
limiting cases.
The first one we want to think
about is when P goes to 0.
So if P goes to 0, what
happens to our answer?
Well, the numerator is 0,
this is 0, this is 1.
But it doesn't matter, because
the numerator is 0.
So in this case, this
would go to 0.
Now does that make sense?
Well, what does that mean
when P goes to 0?
When P goes to 0, that means
that the probability that x is
equal to 1 is 0.
So even without thinking about
y or z, there is already a 0
probability that x
is equal to 1.
Now this whole calculation, what
we found is, well, if I
had some more information, like
what z is, does that help
me find out what the probability
of x being 1 is?
Well, no matter what z tells me,
I know for a fact that x
can't be 1, because P is 0.
So this posterior, or this
conditional probability,
should also be 0, because
there's just no way
that x can be 1.
So in this case, this formula
does check out.
Now let's think about another
case where P goes to 1.
If P goes to 1, that
means that X is for
sure going to be 1.
And it can't be anything else.
In which case, what does
our formula tell us?
Well, this numerator is 1.
This term is 1.
1 minus 1 is 0.
So the second term gets zeroed
out, and the answer
is just 1/1 is 1.
So what does this tell us?
This tells us that if I know
beforehand that x is for sure
equal to 1, then, if I now give
myself more information
and condition on what I observe
for z, that shouldn't
change anything else.
I should still know for sure
that x is equal to 1.
So the probability of this
conditional probability should
still be equal to 1.
And it does, so our formula
also works in this case.
Now let's think about lambda.
What about when lambda
goes to 0?
Well, when lambda goes
to 0, that's a
little harder to visualize.
But really, what would happen
is that you can imagine this
distribution getting shallower,
shallower and
shallower, lower and lower, so
that it's like it is kind of
flat and goes on forever.
And so what this tells you
is that, basically, y--
this is the distribution y-- so
when lambda goes to 0, that
tells you that y has a really
flat and kind of short
distribution.
And so what does our formula
tell us in this case?
Well, when lambda goes to 0,
this exponent is equal to 0.
And so e to the 0 is 1.
So we get P over P plus 1 minus
P, which is just 1.
So the answer here, our formula
will give us an answer
of P.
So what does that tell us?
That tells us that, in this
case, if lambda goes to 0,
then our posterior probability,
the probability
that x equals 1 conditioned
on z being some value,
conditioned on our continuous
measurement, is still P. So
the prior, or the original
probability for x being equal
to 1 is P. And with this
additional continuous
measurement, our guess of the
probability that x equal to 1
is still P. So it
hasn't changed.
So basically, it's telling
us that this additional
information was not
informative.
It didn't actually help
us change our beliefs.
And so why is that?
Well, one way to think about
it is that, because the
distribution of y looks like
this, is very flat and it
could be anything, then, if you
observe some value of z,
then it could be that that was
due to the fact that it was x
equal to 1 plus some value
of y that made z
equal to that value.
Or it could have just as equally
been likely that x
equal to negative 1 y equals to
some other value that made
it equal to z.
And so, essentially, it's z--
because y has a shape, it can be
likely to take on any value
that complements either x being
equal to 1 or x equal
being to negative 1, to make z
equal to whatever the value it
is that you observe.
And so because of that, in
this case, y is not very
informative.
And so this probability is
still just equal to P.
Now the last case is when
lambda goes to infinity.
And now we have to break
it down into the
two other cases now.
The first case is when--
lets write this over here--
when lambda goes to infinity.
The first case, it depends on
what this value is, the sine
of this value.
If this value, the absolute
value of z plus 1 minus the
absolute value of z minus 1,
if that's positive, then,
because lambda goes to infinity
and you have a
negative sign, then this
entire exponential
term will go to 0.
In which case, the second
term goes to 0.
And the answer is
P/P, or is 1.
And so if absolute value of z
plus 1 minus absolute value of
z minus 1 is greater than
0, then the answer is 1.
But in the other case, if this
term in the exponent, if it's
actually negative, if it's
negative, then this negative
sign turns to a positive, and
lambda goes to infinity.
And so this term blows up, and
it dominates everything else.
And so the denominator
goes to infinity.
The numerator is fixed at P,
so this entire expression
would go to 0.
OK, so now let's try to
interpret this case.
Let's start with
the first one.
When is it that absolute value
of z plus 1 minus absolute
value of z minus 1 is
greater than 0?
Or you can also rewrite this as
absolute value of z plus 1
is greater than absolute
value of z minus 1.
Well, when is that case?
Well, it turns out, if you think
about it, this is only
true if z is positive.
If z is positive,
then adding 1--
let me draw a line here, and
if this is 0-- if z is
positive, something here, adding
1 to it and taking the
absolute value--
the absolute value doesn't
do anything--
but you will get something
bigger.
Where subtracting 1 will take
you closer to 0, and so
because of that, the absolute
value, the magnitude, or the
distance from 0 will be less.
Now if you're on the other side,
adding 1 will take you--
if you're on the other side,
adding 1 will take
you closer to 0.
And so this magnitude
would be smaller.
Whereas, subtracting will take
you farther away, so the
absolute value actually
increased the magnitude.
And so this is the same
as z being positive.
as z being negative.
So what this tells you is that,
if z is positive, then
this probability
is equal to 1.
And if z is negative, this
probability is equal to 0.
Now why does that make sense?
Well, it's because when lambda
goes to infinity, you have the
other case.
Essentially, you pull this all
the way up, really, really
far, and it drops off
really quickly.
And so when you take the limit,
as lambda goes to
infinity, effectively, it just
becomes a spike at 0.
And so, more or less, you're
sure that y is going to be
equal to 0.
And so, effectively, z is
actually going to be equal to
x, effectively.
And because of that, because x
can only be 1 or negative 1,
then, depending on if you get a
z that's positive, then you
know for sure that it must
have been that x
was equal to 1.
And if you get a z that's
negative, you know for sure
that it must have been that
x was equal to negative 1.
And so because of that, you
get this interpretation.
And so we've looked at four
different cases of the
parameters.
And in all four cases, our
answer seems to make sense.
And so we feel more confident
in the answer.
And so to summarize, this whole
problem involved using
Bayes' rule.
You start out with some
distributions, and you apply
Bayes' rule.
And you go through the
steps, and you
plug-in the right terms.
And then, in the end, it's
always helpful to try to check
your answers to make sure
that it makes sense
in some of the limiting.